look at that neck you look at that neck
snap never Robert Downey jr. just do
this and like trying to make stuff stick
to him let's say I need to supervise
them here's what stands out to me we
should have our diplomas where's my VFX
diploma hi welcome to VFX artists react
to Margo's bad and good CGI now we've
seen other people do their own versions
of react videos online with different
professionals working in different kinds
of fields we want to do one for
ourselves as visual effects artists and
filmmakers here on YouTube here at
corridor we're going to react to how
Marvel has done their crazy crazy CGI in
their films it's called throw money at
the problem I am Iron Man
this entire shot that you're seeing
right here 100% of every single pixel is
computer-generated really is his fingers
his face his jacket all of that is a
hard percent CG that is one good-looking
CG face
they made an entire main character
that's computer-generated and super
realistic looking I think they nose
looks awesome
over a dozen Studios worked on this
movie so what they do is they have
different levels of detail for certain
shots so they have the highest
resolution highest detailed 3d model of
tano's the space for all like the hero
close-up shots but as soon as it gets
further than like a medium or wide
there's no reason to have all that
detail there you just have you're just
wasting gigabytes of data you're not
gonna see all the pores in his face from
this far away so on his right cheek
there's some pores and little wrinkles
and when he smiles the poorest stretch I
mentioned at the very first one that's
like that kind of stuff there's
technology there for it but such
high-end custom-made technology as those
kind of things will make cases look real
or like the crow's feet on the corners
in the eyes and their skin folding into
those crow's feet these are the kind of
details that you have to get
right have a cg Facebook Nance like you
have to have such specialized knowledge
to make it work it's so crazy notice his
hairs by catching light on the left side
of his face there he has hair I can see
it's like he is double I connect to dad
also currently shaves cuz you're right
he does have something good what does it
mean that he shaves like everybody
that's hilarious dude and now it's
probably just them needing to make
vandals look real and we don't identify
faces the best the hair as being real so
they need to put stubble on him but the
hair itself is catching the light and
shining that means that its physical
hair as part of that model it's sticking
out of him and catching that light it's
not quite human enough to make you
fooled into believing that they're
trying to make him yeah it's not yeah
exactly who's that what what
you can't ask who's who if you haven't
seen the movies
ending fight between Black Panther and
kill monger in Black Panther anytime
people says oh it looks like a
PlayStation game it does such a
disservice to what you're actually
seeing more of an Xbox you know I'll
agree that the scene isn't very well
done but do you know why that ended up
being the case this whole scene they
shot in October and by the time the
visual effects company got it it was
like December they only had about six
weeks to do this entire scene but I got
a good paycheck out of it you can
guarantee that because you're going
overtime doesn't mean you'll get paid
for it that's just the state of the
visual effects industry ok so what
they're given another six months what do
you do with those six months to make
this scene better alright I'm sitting
down I'm going to critique this theme
let's say I need to supervise them
here's what stands out to me first off I
had approached the production designer
and be like why do you have a black
background on a black road in a black
cave
those two guys in black cease fighting
because now there's no way from being
had their silhouettes read we're in a
tricky situation now where I need to be
able to see these figures but they're on
a black background so I need to
artificially just raise the light on the
figure completely from the pop-out so
now he's kind of like gray and black
yeah like there's black on his head just
like it is a farm pit there's like no
contact shadow there's no shadow really
in general in his armpit or like beneath
his head and if you look at the
background the rules of the scene I'm
established that the black levels in the
background go deeper than what you're
seeing on the suit
please just kind of artificially raised
up and that's another thing that's
triggering me you look at his head big
orange black guy in the background his
head is shiny the brightness of that
shine on his head is implying the light
shining on his head
brighter than that but the lights in the
scene around us that we're seeing with
our eyes are not that bright it's a
subtle thing but subconsciously you can
see that it's wrong because you see
light every day one single source of
light really just making a very dramatic
looking image it would have improved it
so much like Jurassic Park or detect
Pikachu you know like it was yeah those
scenes where they use the one source of
light ambient lighting is the death of
realism for visual effects
nothing is ever just ambiently lit I
think I see another issue that's making
selfie they turn their motion blur up a
lot probably to hide some the flaws now
there's a couple of ways when you motion
blur what you're doing Bo Schindler and
CG the quick and easy ways to do
something called motion
vectors we're at four every pixel you
get another pixel that's a color and
that color represents a direction and
later on in the post you can stretch the
pixel out based on that motion vector
that you're getting you make more motion
blur less motion blur it's great for
changing things here's the problem
though it can only describe a direction
so if my hand doesn't arc right and for
that one shutter you're getting an arc
of motion well I can't describe a curve
really describe the direction what I'm
seeing here none of the motion blur
curves every motion blur line is a
straight line there you can see there
it's fish should have had an arc there
there's no highlights that have occurred
or all straight lines so you're saying
that the motion blur isn't baked into
the 3d render it's an actual filter
that's applied on top of it dude I feel
like we're detectives right now because
it like this all makes sense this all
makes sense you you would do that if you
didn't have the time because yeah adding
motion blur
out of straight out of the render adds a
lot of time and there's made the curves
though that's a get the card it's more
realistic that way but but if what if
what we're saying here which sounds
right and looks right they rendered out
a pass and then they added it later
which is a valid thing to do we do it
all the time absolutely all the time
yeah there you see the curves on the
highlights on his ankles there yeah
those that's what the motion blur should
look like and the other scene but you're
not getting any of that this was a great
example actual like more effective
lighting he's sitting next to a light so
you're getting some like volume that's a
good-looking shot right here yeah it
looks great but also bear in mind it's a
little harder to see him because he
blends in with the background a little
bit more so it goes back to the
production design thing you're talking
about a good visual effects shot is more
than just technical prowess it has to
have like artistic vision as well you
have to have all the things that would
make any shot look good go into it just
because it's technically accurate
doesn't mean those things exist
it's really interesting though how like
such a small thing can take people out
it's a bigger challenge for you face the
more high end we go with our effects the
more any tiny little flaw stand out
one thing you can't take away
I am Iron Man that looks good science CG
us real good yeah that looks so cool
this has to be something this is CG yeah
they remade the entire suit
computer-generated so that they can have
all the control they needed and have all
like the little gizmos and stuff moving
that you can't really do with the real
suit so this guy's great look right
there two things they announced me first
the motion is pretty decent for them
putting CG on it ahead the hard thing is
is you have to project shadows onto a
real face so basically to remodel a face
and CG and then use it as a shadow
catcher basically that from the 3d
objects being there to cast a shadow
onto that it looks kind of all right
around the edges of his face there but
what looks really good is when the thing
above his head comes down right there
that shadow looks really solid because
not only is it casting a shadow but it's
removing the shine from his skin there
that's an artist going in there and
taking the time to figure out what the
skin tone would look like in shadow but
also we're moving shine the second touch
that I really like here finger smudges
on the helmet yeah it's so good that's
that's the first thing you should really
learn as a texture artist when it comes
to making textures for CG objects is
surface imperfections that will bring
the realism up from just like oh yeah
that looks real I guess - oh that is a
real thing does this all about the
reference like you have to reference
something like like this chrome helmet I
got on my desk yeah look at that look at
all the imperfections there's like
there's dust on here there's there's
fingerprints on year and the
fingerprints react to light in a
specific way there's like scratches and
wash there's little dust elements it's
more than just a chromed out sphere the
one from Iron Man 2 where he has like
the little briefcase and it suits up I
remember really liking that cuz I
thought it was super now arguably that
suitcase would be as heavy as the suit
you are so right dang it's so cool so
outside here is faces a lot more light
acting on it
just harder to fake a shadow on it so
they just get really fast by having a
helmet close quickly favorite part about
that is the mask itself actually fits
into place like puzzle pieces and all
the seams disappear it's not just the
modeling and the cool lighting and
rendering it's the animation like the
animators are totally killing it here
mm-hmm if the designs for all the
mechanical intricacies and that stuff
you actually have to study mechanical
design can't just bake it on a percent
dude there's so much work that goes into
animating one half every little piece
like all the anchor points are perfectly
locked in and it like when you move one
thing the other thing moves with it it's
just like looking through some space
right there like that would take me like
a week just to animate that it's an idea
of how many people it takes them do a
movie I'm gonna need my suit really fast
here we go I think the first Avengers
film is my favorite Marvel Avengers film
is a wonderful movie the how much
hands-on the stakes are perfect right
there
look at that look love those perfect
shadows on his face this is my only
complaint with this film and a lot of
other films is it's not necessarily the
the actual rendering of the CG stuff
it's the physics of the animation if he
was to actually stop that quickly and
turn around his aorta would just die
inside this there's no he's in a suit he
can follow the sky and just land on the
ground and be tall or fine but it's like
all of his internal organs would be
squished from the momentum it's the same
with Superman when he catches someone
who's following second it exactly be
dead immediately they take my race they
did that in the second spider-man with
Andrew Garfield today for real hmm no no
he slams our head into the ground
what he's a little late and so that she
catches he catches her so she's fallen
to the air
spider-man is chasing after him good
Dewey's you trying to hit the ground
back into the ground full force kind of
she hit that ground dude she's done for
son
wait go frame-by-frame her friend dude
she bounced she bounced they look at
that neck do you look at that neck snap
sweet and this is Vegas like when
something moves their fingers you got
track tomorrow over it that's a lot of
work this is just like how difficult
three [ __ ] stood up sequence for our
visual effects artist that's what this
is right here she's never Robert Downey
jr. just do this and like try to make
stuff stick to him anytime you see a CG
thing and there's a flair over the top
of that that Flair was recreated for
that shot yeah hopefully it wasn't it
wasn't like a cutout and put back on top
it was literally created from scratch
and put on top yeah I think this is a
very realistic looking suit it matches
the scene the black levels are all
messed like it looks real if there's a
flare over like where you want to put a
CG element problem is like you have a
half transparent like color circle and
somehow you need to like mask it out to
put it on top your footage even though
it's half transparent it's like trying
to mask out a window you can't really do
that I'm not solution is to literally
just recreate like the the director of
photography needs to choose lenses here
that don't flare for the visual effects
elements so they can add the flaring
later that's that's some
forward-thinking onset for sure who are
you in this vast multitudes hasting
Doctor Strange Clint I'm not I think
you'll dig this I actually really
enjoyed Doctor Strange I I thought it
was pretty trippy and fun and who
doesn't like Mads Mikkelsen come on
Doctor Strange does some pretty cool
stuff so far dang and this little the
color love the vibes is awesome really
cool stuff here is like dreamlike
architecture is just changing and
warping and clanging and moving which is
such a great use of CG or it's like
we're not trying to make it real we're
Stanton bracelet computers can do well
and that's recursive procedural fractal
animation which looks so cool yeah you
can actually do a lot of those particle
effects while using After Effects
and trapcode particular which is a
particle plug-in or after-effects you
can do a lot of that same sort of stuff
dude that's crazy why is he running when
he has this flying choreographic
perspective even you'd like a weird like
well the cars projection mapping thing
to orthographic perspective doesn't have
actual like vanishing points so
something that's close to you this thing
is far from you are the exact same size
like an architectural drawing it only
exists in CG and I love it it just went
for it there it's awesome we need you to
run down the street and do this okay but
now you see the entire city bending
around and moving that's awesome
whoa there's stuff so cool I love you
can just get inventive and kooky and
weird which other facial effects buttons
I'm tired of seeing people blow millions
of dollars just like blowing stuff up
yeah this is cool so that would really
cool stuff like super imaginative like
Wow showing me things I have never seen
before
yeah your team of artists crazy cameras
like this is so great like I don't care
this that was CG it's fun to watch yeah
trigger this thing where you can't quite
follow it it's like watching one of like
Google's deep dream videos it's like
what am I looking at like I see things
that I can parse but I yet I can't
actually place them into something this
but it's not a visual mess either yeah
no everything's thought-out here this is
incredible man so full CG characters
time for something that that right there
I honestly don't know they're so good
you can never like just tell by looking
at it whether or not a character is
digital versus for real like for a lot
of that stuff it's probably easier to do
it digitally oh it's over I could just
keep watching
that's an awesome that's super
satisfying to watch man yeah there's
there's like VFX that try to replicate
real life and then there's VFX that look
like real life and then mess with it
like that or like an inception but
that's also a little bit of kind of like
what we do here at corridor we kind of
like try to find novel twists on things
that you are already familiar with
because like I'm like how can we make it
different exactly that was what
movie did they just they took a city
everyone's familiar with the city and
they just did some really crazy
different things with it it is that
80/20 Man got to get that 20% unfamiliar
20% fresh in the movie in game there
they have those white suits have you
seen the trailer where they're all
wearing those white suits mm-hmm well
for all you guys who have seen the movie
in-game all those white suits every
single one of them is digital or they
didn't exist when they shot the movie
because they didn't have the design for
them at the time they did when they shot
the movie they are all fake why every
single white suit in this movie is fake
and no one complains about it because no
one was able to tell if they were fake
they thought they were real costumes
Patrick Williams I loved his video
essays and he made a point on Twitter
about like why didn't they just design
the suits like why not just have the
suits for filming it's like whoa there's
a million different things that maybe
are just not ready in time for the time
of shooting building costumes a deal
with already with the Avengers yeah and
it's like your final product doesn't
represent the trouble you went through
to get to that point so that was
probably one of those troubles is like
we don't have the suits designed yet and
so it's not a problem it's it's now an
asset that they can use for making the
movie I bet the collars wheel we have
had incredible reception making this
visual text artist react because we look
forward to making many more but we need
your help
leave a comment below with any movies
shows music videos things that you think
would be great to react to and we will
take it we're gonna
it happen what do you guys want
Bollywood The Matrix we got all that
stuff plan we need more ideas guys but
maybe in the meantime check out the crew
channel that this is on and if you want
to see some of our visual effects check
out the corridor channel